I'm doing.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
As per usual for our Saturday nights,
inshallah we will begin immediately with
the questions and answers.
and save.
[Arabic recitation]
start.
my question is how do you see the
state of the Muslim world today? How do
you see the state of the because
from my perspective the way I see
it that we have more Muslims than ever.
We have more mosques than ever. we
have more schools than ever. But also it
feels it's kind of quantity
quantity but but not quality because
feels iman is weak in people. it
feels a lot of people are chasing
the world and you know for example
you see a lot of people just in
you see the you know for example in
mosques and stuff you see them coming
Friday Eid Ramadan you don't see Quran
being recited that much you see it like
you know recit Ramadan that kind of
stuff. so just kind of interested in
your kind of opinion on that matter.
Alhamdulillah.
Without a doubt,
our modern time,
we see
a huge
appearance
of Islam.
Probably more
[Silence]
the question I think it was pretty
clear. The question is, you know, we see
that there's a lot of Muslims today.
However, how
quality and qualitative is that Islam in
a nutshell?
And yes, without a doubt, Islam is
probably more
apparent
in ways in ways than it has been in the
past or few times in the past.
However,
the problem is that this appearance and
this prevalence
and the ubiquitous pres presence of
Islam in today's world is a cheap
very thin veneer.
It's very akin to a facade.
And this is not my words. This is not my
assessment.
This is an assessment that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam made centuries
ago.
There's an narration in a sunnah in
which the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
said
[Silence]
forch.
that is sick.
This authentic nar narration here kind
of brings into perspective
a lot of what we see today.
He said saiam
a time will come
when the nations of the world invite one
another to partake in your pillaging.
Just guests
invite one another to eat at a dish.
So imagine here the imagery that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
giving us here. He says,
Foreimch.
[Silence]
Wasam.
Zed.
He said
that a time is near
when the nations of the world
will invite and beckon and urge one
another to feast on you, on you all. on
the Muslims to pillage you just as a
group of eaters invite and beckon one
another.
You have a a big meal, right, on on a
plate on a on a on a big you know,
what do they call this? You know, a big
platter, right? And it's got all this
food on it. And you know, we're all
eating from the same platter, the way
that we would invite one another to eat,
right? we see, you know, eat, take
more, take, you know, you didn't take
that much, you didn't eat that much.
Come on. Right? This here is the imagery
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
gives us. He says that a time is coming
when the Muslims in that scenario
are going to be that dish and platter
and the rest of the world's nations
are going to be those
feasters, those gluttonous beings
beckoning and inviting one another to
partake and pillaging the Muslims.
So
you notice that this imagery is
incredibly haunting.
Why is it so haunting?
Because just as that platter is helpless
to defend itself.
Likewise,
the ones who are eating it, inviting one
another to it, they are the ones that
control how much of is taken of it and
how much of it is pillaged.
Now, the companions
heard this in a time when the messenger
was amongst them. They heard this on the
heels of the moon being split. They
heard this on the heels of the battle of
They heard this on the heels of the
great victories of Islam.
They heard this and the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam had otherwise told
them that the bracelets of the emperor
of Persia is going to be had and worn by
ib Malik in the streets of Medina.
That's what he said. He said that Ibin
Malik,
who was not a Muslim at the time, was
going to wear the bracelets of the
emperor of Persia in the streets of
Medina. And that happened in the time of
Omar.
It was unfathomable
that the Muslims would go from that to
a time is going to come when the nations
are going to feast on your
on on on the Muslim.
And so the companions couldn't really
understand why such a thing would
happen.
And so they said, "Is that because we
will be few in numbers
at that time?
We're too few to defend ourselves. Is
that because we will be so few in
numbers?"
He said
he said no to the contrary
on that day and in that era you all will
be extremely numerous many Muslims all
over.
However, the Islam, the quality of that
Islam
and that practice
will be the foam that is carried a
top a river, right? When the waters
gush,
if we could have the children please
quiet down a little bit, especially
right under the dome, it echoes very
distracting. So if we were to look at a
river when the waters are crashing,
right? What happens when those waters
crash or even on a beach where the water
comes up on shore? It produces a foam
that's carried on top of this on top of
this river, right? And that foam
makes the
river appear bigger than it actually
is. Right? If we were to stop the water
and let the water settle, right?
We would lose many inches from the
height of that
river or that water. Are you all
understanding the imagery here? So the
point is is that foam
because there's so much air in it, it
expands
and it strikes the
onlooker
as being
you know a as as being part of the
river but actually the water is much
less dense than that.
So the point that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam is telling us
here is that the quantity of the muslim
during those days will be more than
ever. However, the quality of that Islam
that is practiced will be what? Far less
than it appears. It's just an appearance
of quantity.
Now if we look at that and we were
trying we were attempting to translate
that into our current affair as Muslim
is that narration speaking specifically
about the state of the Muslim in 2025
I can't say that who knows Allah
that is something that I have no way of
knowing or any other human being has any
way of knowing. knowing the exact year
when that example and prophecy will be
epitomized. Right? However, what we do
know is that the more we go on into the
future, the nearer we go to epitomizing
and actualizing that state of affairs.
If we were to look at the state of the
affairs of the Muslim,
we no longer fight for ourselves.
We don't defend ourselves anymore. Our
best defense is to beg
our enemies or to beg onlookers to
please intervene on our behalf. That's
the most we can do now. We have nothing
else.
The most we can we we find ourselves
doing is look at the atrocities that are
happening in Gaza for instance. Why is
it where's your humanity? Where's the
humanity? Begging the world to relieve
us of our burden. That's our burden.
Why is it that we are expecting that the
rest of the world should care?
Right? And so this
is
as weak as a person can become when they
are completely at the mercy of
onlookers.
We we we say to the other nations, "Look
at the footage. Look at the the body
parts in the streets. Look at the
explosions in great detail, in graphic
detail,
showing the bodies of men and Muslim men
and women and children all all scattered
throughout the streets and begging the
world because now we say we have to
spread awareness." That is that is the
height of our strength now is to spread
awareness.
I don't know how much weaker it could
get.
I honestly I cannot envision how much
weaker
our situation could get. How much more
dire our situ situation could get.
Now a person may say why is that? Why
why is that happening?
You know, we're not perfect, but the
Muslim
are
you know, upon guidance. Correct. Why
is it that the Muslim blood is the
cheapest blood? And why is it that the
Muslim
woman is often the most
abused in society? Why is it that we are
such a soft target?
The entire battle
that took place with Benin Noah
when they were completely removed from
the entire Arab Peninsula
is because
a Jewish man from amongst them tied a
Muslim woman's clothing in such a way
that when she stood up. It showed her
leg
and she yelled out for the Muslims
and they entire
tribe
was eradicated from the Arab Peninsula
because of that one time.
That's where we came from
and here we are today.
that we take highdefinition 8K cameras
and point it at the blood and body parts
of children and women and men.
And we can't get any sympathy.
We would ask cordially one more time if
please
the children could be quieted down.
And so
we see that that's where we came from
and this is where we have arrived.
Why is that? Why he have why have we
arrived at that junction? This is what
we have to ask ourselves
and that is because of how the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam described our
situation. What did he describe it as?
Numerous
high in numbers
but it is the foam a top a stream.
Okay, those numbers yes are are very
high numbers. The fastest growing
religion in the west and the fastest
growing religion in prisons and the
fastest growing religion amongst women
and the f you know all these statistics
that we get right
fantastic that is great. But the quality
of that Islam
when we look at the veneer the facade
from the outside we say yeah mashallah
you know look how many apps for the
mus how many apps show us the mus how
many apps on the recitation of the Quran
are made and exist right now in the app
stores a lot.
How many of them focus on understanding
the Quran?
You can hardly find anything that.
Recitation of the Quran,
mashallah.
Understanding the Quran,
it's almost it's becoming a a a lost
ancient art of sorts.
Muslims that are 40, 50, 60 years old,
they've been saying
for 60 70 years
and many of them don't know what the
word means. It just never occurred to
them to ask what does that mean?
It never occurred
to
say this is our religion. We don't do
that. There's not a new fad that is ever
introduced into the world except that
the Muslim
will most often accept it with open arms
even though it becomes incredibly
destructive to us. The point here is
that it is not an issue of quantity.
Quantity has never been the cause for
victory in Islamic history. Ever. Ever.
Never one time. If you look at the
Quran, Allah never mentions a large
group
without mentioning something disparaging
about it. And he never mentions a
minority without praising that minority.
And all
of the
endeavors of the Muslim, they were never
judged by
quantity.
It was always what? Quality. Right now,
a person could hold up a a cell phone
and have in it the entire
library of the Muslim that has been
printed today thousands upon th tens of
thousands of books
with every with with 1500 years worth of
knowledge. However,
ignorance has never been more prevalent.
Right? And these are the things that the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
prophesized
and it is a great gift and wisdom from
Allah that if the Muslims are not
quality and they are not authentic
and genuine that they not be the ones
who govern the world. Why? Because if we
were given reward
for our shortcomings in this life, it
would only reinforce our shortcomings.
It would not cause us to take a look at
ourselves and try to change things.
The issue is that we have certain
certain things that we have adopted and
we're not even sure where they came
from. A lot of it has come from years
and years of brainwashing, years and
years of you know colonialism and
we're speaking about mental,
psychological and otherwise, right? And
humanity at large is at a deficit in
their existence at large. I'm not
speaking about technology. I'm speaking
about morality. Knowledge. Knowledge,
not invention, not money. knowledge,
right? Genuine genu general knowledge.
We have human beings in droves that
don't even know the difference between
north and south and east and west. And
if the electricity went out tomorrow, we
wouldn't know how to tie our shoes cuz
we didn't have an app to tell us how to
do it. This is a deficit that all of
humanity is in today. We don't know how
to hunt. We don't know how to clean
ourselves. We don't know how to do a lot
of things as human beings. The Muslims
alhamdulillah they are not ever as bad
as the rest of humanity will get in the
way of morality and the way but we will
be affected by that because we all
inhabit the earth together. Therefore,
the state of the Muslim today is a lack
of knowledge and a lack of
concentration on the hereafter and a
huge focus on the dunya. When we say a
huge focus on the dunya, the dunya has
become primary and the hereafter has
become secondary. They can't both be the
same. You cannot. It's impossible to
hold the dunya and the hereafter in the
same regard. You have to choose one.
Which one is primary and which one is
secondary?
We have Muslim
men and women marriages who when they
have a dispute they are resorting to
chat GPT to tell them they're res to to
tell them which one of them is right
and which one of them is wrong. We have
products like
GPT,
right?
We have people Muslim who take their
religion from Facebook and WhatsApp.
No one who takes something seriously
takes from these places. This is not a
place of education. This is
entertainment,
right? And so it doesn't occur to many
Muslims to look to the Quran for
judgment. It doesn't occur to many
Muslims to understand what the Quran
says, what the Sunnah says. And a lot of
this comes from again the dunya is
primary, the hereafter is secondary. And
our dean has suffered because of it.
When will that go back to the way it
was?
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam said
[Silence]
listen to this narration and I want you
to contemplate its true meanings with
He saidam
he mentioned three things three state of
affairs.
He said number one if you as the Muslims
began to deal in
which is a type of ribba but it's not
a parentba I will explain it in detail
in a moment inshallah. He said if if the
Muslim start to deal in a
he says
and grab and hold on and follow the
tales of cattle
and leave off and abandon.
Allah will concentrate a humiliation
upon you all until you go back to your
religion.
Listen to the wording of the narration.
The first thing he mentioned the first
symptom. These are all symptoms.
Those three traits they are symptoms.
What are they symptoms of? Symptoms that
the Muslims have abandoned epitomizing
their religion.
So what are the symptoms? Listen closely
to the subtleties. He said
what is
but it's ribba that looks it's
halal.
Okay, I'll explain it to you now. Let's
say I have a shop,
a store, right? I sell rice
and
let's say that Fed wanted to come in
and he he needs some money. He's
strapped for cash,
but
he doesn't want to tell me I need $10
and I'll pay you back $11.
Because that's ribba, correct? If we
agree on that, I say I will I will lend
you $10 if you pay me back is $11. This
is what this is the clearest most
clearcut ribba. Okay? So, we don't do
that cuz we're Muslim and we don't deal
with ribba. So, what do we do? Fed comes
in and he says,
"I would to purchase from you a bag
of rice,
but I want to purchase it on
consignment.
I'll pay you back for it next week."
Okay,
cool.
So, I'm selling him a bag of rice
and I'm writing it in my as a debt on
the ledger, right? So, the bag of rice
costs $10.
So, now
he buys that bag of rice from me. The
rice hasn't moved and it will not move
from its place this entire transaction.
Now he owns this bag of rice. He says,
"I will now sell you that bag of rice. I
want to sell it back to you.
How much do you want to sell it to me
for?" I say, "I'll buy it from you for
$11."
Okay.
So now
he sells me back the bag of rice
at a lower cost.
I have written that he owes me $11
when I have actually given him 10 and
the bag of rice sits in its same place.
The transaction looks it was buying
and selling but there was no buying and
selling that took place. He left with
$10. He came back with $11 and the bag
of rice did not move from its place.
This type of transaction is referred to
as
in in Islamic it is called
and so what does this mean? This means
that when the Muslim start to do what is
haram
but give it the appearance of being
halal. That's what the narration is
talking about. when they start to do
what is haram
but they do it in such a way that it
appears to be halal from the outside. So
they give it a Muslim name. They stamp
it with
okay now we have ribba but this is
Islamic ribba. Now this is the point of
the narration. He says,
"And you follow the tales of cattle,
cattle in the Arabic language at that
time is viewed as being a very precious
commodity." Meaning that your sole focus
is money. And wherever that cow goes,
you're following its tail wherever it
goes. And you will follow it wherever it
goes. That is what is leading your way,
not the other way around. Your money is
not following you. You are following
your money now.
And so here we have doing that which is
haram but giving it a halal spin
through a technicality. Number two,
following the dunya and making it
primary and the the hereafter secondary.
Number three, leaving off and abandoning
al Jihad. Jihad is not just an issue of
preserving and protecting Islam. Every
major empire, if it hopes to
if it hopes to survive, must be in
constant expansion. It has to be and it
has to have military
it has to have military
endeavors throughout the world looking
out for the welfare of its its its
government or not its government but its
state. Any state that is neutral and has
no military, this state will never be a
major player ever. And they will always
be pawns to other major empires.
So these three symptoms articulate what
foam the foam of a river.
Allah said, the prophet said,
sallallah.aii wasallam, Allah will
concentrate upon you all as a whole.
A humiliation.
The Muslim blood is the cheapest blood.
We're begging our enemies to just have
mercy on us, right? That's where we're
at until you return to your religion.
And the only way that the Muslim will
return to our religion is when things
become unavoidable.
We will not be able to ignore it
anymore.
We won't be able to take it anymore.
Then we will go back to our religion as
a whole or as a majority. We are not
Christians. We are not other
religions. We don't wait for a savior to
come and save us. Al Mahi is going to
come and save us. If the MAI came out
today, the Muslim out of ignorance would
kill him themselves and think that
they're doing a service to Islam. Al
Mahi cannot come out amongst an ummah
that is so deeply divided that a masid
cannot even maintain order. one building
to pray in cannot maintain order without
deep politics the Cold War of a of
of of the 60s and 70s. Espionage and
spies and and and listening and right
over what over a building and who's
going to lead salah? This is where we're
at. So, as long as this is the
situation, the Mahi will not emerge to
lead a people that are that. He
will emerge a head ready to be fit
on a good healthy body as the scholars
of Islam have described him. we have
completed our time for this evening.
That wasn't really a question. That's
not really what our our gathering is
for. That's more of a topic, right?
However, inshallah I hope that we will
have benefited
and no matter what no matter how bad
things get for the of Islam,
it is the greatest of nations to ever be
on this earth. And it every great nation
has
depressions.
Every great nation just every great
man becomes ill and has times of
weakness. This is a moment of weakness.
How do we repair it? We repair it one
person, one family at a time.
Now I am not going to focus on how do I
fix the whole ummah. No, I'm going to
focus on how do I fix my kids and my
family? How do I fix myself? She Ali is
not going to focus on all of Instagram
and how he's going to be a super sheh
and take over the world on Instagram and
fix all the Muslim by talking. That's
that doesn't fix the world. We don't
need superstars
and super shik. What does she Ali need
to do? Focus on MCCCT here right now.
Right. Our recording is a service for
our community members. That's all it is
for. This is how we go back to our
religion. One person at a time, one
family at a time. We re-examine the
bricks of our building. Every time we
add a brick to our wall, we make sure
that it is good through and through
according to the book of Allah and the
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. We weed out the bad. We
practice the good. We hold to that which
we are certain of. We reject what we are
uncertain of. And the days of glory are
are ahead.
But this is part of the process of this
that our prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam told us would occur. It's just
that we are unfortunate enough to be
part of that time. Now
All subal
and
subhan
[Silence]
Islam.
All subm